most watched show on television people
love this program you are so mean I mean
there is no such cruelty
to the show and you know I see it just
watching the show but then I found out
that you yourself can be quite cruel
taunting funny I don't make a thing of
it but yes yes yeah well I what I'm
saying is you like to taunt the fans
with who's going to die when it's not
true is that right I have a lot of fun
with that yeah I mean I do a lot of
interviews and a lot of people don't
know that I can't answer the who dies
next question right and I get it so
often that I just started answering it
inaccurately right and it and it brings
me no end of delight to be able to just
go oh Michonne does next you know or oh
no Rick dies in this next episode and
every single time the person that's
interviewing me is like oh my god really
and it's never true
yeah well actually in a weird way the
reverse is true if you say that it means
they don't die that's the key that's the
key and I get people that are mad at me
because I poke fun like that but I'm
just like guys I'm throwing you a bone
yeah if I answer the question that means
that person is definitely not done safe
for a little while
yeah very little while yeah in some
cases I have to say we just watched this
clip with with negan in it who I think
is one of the meanest characters I've
seen on television I mean since Al Roker
you don't know I'm in person he's a
monster yeah you can tell no no no but
really negan I mean there's a whole this
is now a that you don't know we don't
need no selling this as a toy this is
yeah there's one of our staff members
got this as a toy I'm not gonna hit you
with it
it's unless you tell me who dies
and then next episode it's Michelle but
uh but I you know there's been a lot of
toys sold at toy stores the fact that
this is a toy blows my mind
it's not narrable mom I want the bat the
guy beat the guy's head in with um yeah
can I get that yeah I think you can't
get hurt with it though that's the
beauty of this model right here unless
you swing it at someone's head yeah yeah
the actual barbed wire pieces are rubber
but the bat itself is fairly solid yeah
also but the barbed wire in terms of
Skull Crushing it's just show it's no go
oh yeah it's just a battle crush your
skull as well as one wrapped in barbed
yeah the barbed wire is really not
helping it just looks cool okay yeah
just checking that for the folks at home
yeah and he's a real toy right yeah I'm
just saying if you want to split a head
you don't have to dress it up
[Applause]
you